le bus de la création c'est un programme
de sensibilisation itinérant c'est à
dire qu'on se déplace dans toute
l'ile-de-france et donc paris pour aller
vers les personnes les accueillir
gratuitement pour les présenter les
dispositifs d'accompagnement à la
création d'entreprise
la tournée du bus sur paris saclay est
organisée en collaboration avec la
communauté paris saclay avec la maison
de la création d'entreprise
de longjumeau et nous avons fait en deux
semaines 14 étapes
le public on reçoit est assez hétérogène
nous avons des demandeurs d'emploi des
salariés des jeunes des personnes de
tout âge de tout secteur et qui vient
effectivement à différents niveaux de
leur projet à l'initiative est
favorablement accueillie par les
personnes qui sans surprise de le voir
venir à leur rencontre comme ça pour
leur réponse finalement de manière
gratuite et de manière assez pointu
aussi puisque ce sont des conseillers
expérimentés qui répondent à leurs
questions et qu'ils ont appris les
oriente pour pouvoir mieux structurer
leurs projets depuis deux ans que le bus
existants région ile de france nous
avons touché 50 territoire en change
d'endroit toutes les semaines et
pratiquement tous les jours et donc nous
avons touché près de 3500 personnes qui
auraient été accueillis et orientés dans
le bus de la création d'entreprise
je suis ravi que le bus création
d'entreprise soient présents aujourd'hui
sur le parvis la mairie d'orsay parce
qu'on fait un grand nombre d'initiatives
pour créer de l'emploi sur le territoire
alors il ya souvent des structures
existantes ya des lieux de rendez vous
il n'y a pas un moment itinérant comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui avec une
structure bg&e qui propose de réunir
tous les acteurs et qui est ouvert pour
se faire connaître pour répondre aux
questions même si elles sont très
techniques des gens aux premières idées
et surtout pour leur faire part de
toutes les structures existantes et du
parcours à suivre pour aller jusqu'au
bout des projets et jusqu'à la création
d'entreprise ça reste pour nous
l'objectif essentiel du cluster paris
saclay c'est pas uniquement rassembler
toute la recherche l'enseignement
supérieur mais aussi permettre
l'innovation et permettent la création
des start up et des entreprises de
demain
donc c'est une journée expérimental
j'espère qu'ils se reproduira
régulièrement sur notre territoire